[Musique]
laborde la cyber sécurité il est
vraiment au fondement de ce qu'on
voudrait réussir comme le repas d'apt et
à la transformation numérique
[Musique]
cela concerne nos données personnelles
sur la concerne la sécurité de nos
services de nos produits
cela concerne tout simplement la
sécurité de notre économie et de notre
société
nous avons besoin d'experts aujourd'hui
il manque 300 mille experts en
cybersécurité
[Musique]
comment attirer la jeunesse je crois que
si on trouve des méthodes adaptées pour
chaque âge parce que ce n'est pas la
même la même chose aux primaires quand
dans l'université de montrer tout
simplement l'extraordinaire diversité
des métiers de cyber on a plus de
chances d'avoir des jeunes
nous avons besoin de nos enseignants les
enseignants qu'ils puissent parler les
métiers de la cybersécurité qu'ils
puissent avoir accès à des formations en
ce moment nous avons quarante et une
alliance européenne les universités
c'est notre grande initiative pour
l'espace européen de l'éducation qui
doit être réalisé d'ici 2025
[Musique]
collectivités territoriales entend rôle
fondamental à jouer je ne me réjouis que
dans le domaine de la recherche de
l'innovation de l'éducation de la
culture pour la première fois nous avons
décidé ensemble avec le comité des
régions de faire un plan d'action
conjoint pour les deux prochaines années
pour nous le rôle des régions sur la
fondamentale et pour la transformation
numérique et pour la nécessité d'avoir
plus de personnes qui ont les
compétences numériques de base et
avancées nécessaires pour créer des
entreprises pour créer des stars table
pour permettre à nos services
administratifs électronique d'être au
plus haut point